thank you
[Music]
this episode is sponsored by Squarespace
go to squarespace.com microcosmos to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
[Music]
a useful principle in the story of life
is that you should never underestimate
algae or cyanobacteria they will always
manage to surprise you and more
importantly to remind you that
everything you have ultimately comes
down to them You Like Oxygen well take
some time to thank a cyanobacterium if
their ancestors hadn't gone a little
Haywire with their photosynthesis and
set off the great oxidation event
billions of years ago we would not exist
but you don't even have to look back
into history to see the influence of
algae and cyanobacteria today even algae
of the smallest size have a tremendous
impact on our lives both good and bad on
the one hand they translate sunlight
into food through photosynthesis on the
other hand they bloom in waters and
release toxins that can wreak damage on
the organisms around them
but the real reason that you should
never underestimate algae or
cyanobacteria is because at their core
they are organisms that seem to just
always find a way they exist in super
salty Waters in ponds in Hot Springs
though these are of course aquatic
organisms and so you might think of
their adaptations as restricted to
watery environments but what has made
algae so capable of existing Beyond
those boundaries is their willingness to
use other organisms as a means to their
own Survival at times their symbiotic
relationships sound absurd like the
species that makes a home out of sloth
fur but our favorite example of the
creativity that algae and cyanobacteria
approach their relationships with has to
be likened that combination of fungus
and algae or fungus and cyanobacteria
that attaches to trees and rocks and
anything else that sits around long
enough the concept of a lichen appears
to be simple enough there's a fungus
which has an incredible capacity for
spreading and decomposing but no means
to make its own food and then there's
the algae or cyanobacteria fully capable
of making their own food but in need of
some help getting around on land the
result is called a dual organism made up
of the fungal microbiot and the algal
photobiont that takes on the spreading
qualities of the first and the colors of
the second
[Music]
fungi and algae can meet and work
together in ways that actually don't
result in a lichen the distinct
structure that we associate with lichens
comes down to the phallus made up of
distinct layers that reveal the
different combinations of the organisms
that make it the phallus is what allows
lichen to survive keeping the organisms
alive in dry conditions so that it can
tolerate Extremes in humidity and
temperature the shape is generally a
function of the fungus which starts to
weave its body into the appropriate
layers as soon as it comes upon algae to
team up with at the edge is the cortex
where the fungal cells are thicker and
close in contact so they can form a
protective structure and beneath it
keeps a more fibrous and loose mass of
hyphy a scaffolding structure called the
medulla that the photobions layer
themselves on dividing and creating
their own algal layer that's large and
green and positioned to access the Sun
that layer of cells tells us a little
bit more about the organisms inside the
Lichen though only under the right
conditions a dry lichen is typically
gray but with water the fungal gray
clears up revealing the color of the
photobions inside the Lichen in the case
of algae photobions you'll typically see
a bright green color but when there are
cyanobacteria the Hues vary from dark
green to Black now lichens have to
actually stick to the thing that they
are stuck to and they have a few ways to
Anchor themselves onto surfaces some
have a structure called a hold fast that
extends as part of the thalis a bit like
a peg it's very good at holding onto
things like rock our like in here though
uses a different type of structure
called rhizons These are threads that
come from the medulla or lower cortex
creeping out from the lichen-like roots
only they do not have any kept capacity
to draw in nutrients they're just
anchors now from our perspective right
now there's nothing controversial about
this partnering of fungus and algae we
look in the Lichen and we see signs of
both organisms and boil it down to a
simple exchange of protection for food
this ancient relationship brought algae
onto land and into places so different
from their watery Origins but our
understanding of lichens as not just one
organism but two is actually relatively
recent going back only to 1867 when a
Swiss botanist named Simon swindoner
presented his work at these Swiss
Natural History Society he'd been
looking at lichen under the microscope
just as we are now when he considered
the possibility that the mass of hyphy
he was looking at belonged to a fungus
wrapped around algae is contemporary
lichenologists did not a three sure
swindoner was just one of multiple
scientists who had noted a resemblance
between the parts of lichen and the
bodies of fungi and algae but that was
just a resemblance it seemed to the
likenologists at the time in their
defense they did not know that a dual
organism could exist they did not know
that there was a symbiosis here how
could they when the word symbiosis
hadn't been invented yet swindoner had
more reasons than just appearances
though one challenge that lycanologists
repeatedly came across was that it was
impossible to grow a new lichen from
isolating either the spores or the green
cells growing within the Lichen but in
1877 a scientist named Albert Bernhard
Frank came up with the term symbiosis
the organism that inspired him to come
up with that word well of course it was
lichen Frank was one of several
biologists intrigued by the possibility
of swindoner's hypothesis this idea that
organisms could live together not just
in an environment but in one entity
now with time lycanologists came around
and people only uncovered more examples
and more nuances around symbiosis but
that does not mean that we actually
understand lichen they remain
challenging to cultivate in a lab and
we're still trying to understand whether
the symbiosis we've reduced to a simple
meeting of two organisms might actually
be more complex whether it can involve
other species as well perhaps there's a
way to describe lichens and the world
inside of them that we just don't know
yet a word that like symbiosis will
reveal something new and remarkable to
us about our world the way we talk about
science and knowledge sometimes makes it
feel like we're done that science is a
static set of all of the facts in the
universe because it is a lot easier to
talk about things that we know than
things that we don't of course it's hard
to talk about the things that we don't
know because we don't know them but our
world is always there containing the
information that we want in everyday
occurrences that are sometimes hundreds
of millions of years old we humans just
have to figure out ways to ask the
questions that will actually give us
answers
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
and thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring
this episode Squarespace gives people a
powerful and beautiful online platform
from which to create their website so
whether you're looking to create an
online portfolio start a blog or open an
online store Squarespace can help you
out maybe it's finally time to start
that photography blog you've been
thinking about well Squarespace has the
tools you need they make it super simple
to categorize schedule and share your
blog posts and once your blog takes off
you're going to want to connect with
your audience and guess what Squarespace
can help you out there as well you can
interact with your community on your
Squarespace site through threaded
comments and replies and can even
generate extra Revenue through members
only content and if you decide you want
to start selling prints to your
fantastic photos well you already know
what I'm gonna say Squarespace can help
you out there as well Squarespace is
already a powerful e-commerce platform
but you can even go the extra mile and
add third-party extensions to help you
manage Tory streamlined bookkeeping and
ship products across the world and you
can do all of this with one easy to use
platform so go to squarespace.com to
sign up for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch go to squarespace.com
microcosmos to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
the folks on the screen right now they
are our patreon patrons they're the
people who make it possible for me to
sit here at my desk and just be
absolutely amazed and astounded by the
completely invisible beauty of our world
that we can only see and understand
because of the extremely hard work of
literally millions of people from the
very first microscopists until now I'm
so glad that we get to make this show
and if you want to help us out you can
do that by going to patreon.com journey
to micro if you want to see more from
our master of microscopes James Weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]
thank you